l'histoire de sourire et à défaut de
sondages actualisées sur les
présidentielles permettez moi de faire
un petit clin d'oeil à la classe
politique
vsd et la sofres publié un sondage sur
les français et l'amour
23% des personnes interrogées
reconnaissent qu'il leur arrive de
s'ennuyer en faisant l'amour et la
classe politique dans tout cela vous
inquiétez pas j'y arrive
il semblerait que le parti communiste et
le front national soit plus atteints que
les autres pascal deschamps n'a pas
hésité elle a tendu son micro aux
intéressés première élue le rpr 18%
seulement de ses sympathisants avoue
s'ennuyer en faisant l'amour en faisant
l'amour
moi mais je me suis jamais ennuyé nulle
part ceux qui se proclament comme
lecteur rpr s'ennuie moins grise autres
alors ça prouve qu'on apprend dans une
plus grande capacité au bonheur et
j'espère qu'on en fait bénéficier notre
entourage
l'udf 25 % de sympathisants s'ennuie au
lit
très bien ce que nous pouvons faire pour
je veux bien que
légiférer lyon mais je doute fort que si
nos institutions une loi autorisant les
français ou les obligeant à ne pas
s'ennuyer lorsqu'il se livrent à l'acte
de la procréation
je ne sors que nous ayons des résultats
même pourcentage chez les socialistes
je pense par exemple à ce renfort à
l'assemblée nationale le lendemain à la
réception que je vais avoir aux costumes
que je vais mettre le matin à l'autre
toilette voilà un tas de choses comme ça
elle permet donc de faire son programme
pour la journée du lendemain front
national 28 % d'insatisfaits
je m'excuse de vous le dire on a fait
certainement la faute des françaises
alors il faudrait que les françaises
soit un peu plus porté sur les choses de
l'amour d'après ce moment là et je pense
pour un certain nombre peut-être un peu
moins sur les choses à la politique
revoyez votre endroit on s'ennuie -
gérer difficilement
bons derniers les communistes le sujet
les ennuis tellement que pas un n'a
voulu nous en parler